bild reporter paul ronzheimer war den
ganzen tag über dort und das sind seine
bilder
dokumente von kriegsverbrechen
zivilisten erschossen zuvor gefesselt
wehrlos
ermordet vom fahrrad heruntergeschossen
der hund verharrt neben seinem herrchen
beim kartoffeln holen abgeknallt
frauen unter decken nackt offenbar zuvor
vergewaltigt
bild dokumentiert diese verbrechen
die leichen in säcke gepackt werden nach
tagen die sie würdelos in den straßen
lagen
diese bilder sind nur schwer zu ertragen
sie sind beweise russischer gräueltaten
die schreckliche steigerung von krieg
bei mir ist der botschafter der ukraine
hier in deutschland andrej melik das
sind ihre menschen die dort in diesen
leichensäcken liegen
ja herr weise wir haben mit meiner frau
schon in diesem 39 tagen so oft geweint
dass das uns jetzt einfach trennen nicht
mehr fließen können wir haben diese
nachts nicht schlafen können weil
diese vor ort das ist so wie babelsberg
oder potsdam für für für für berlin da
waren meine freunde
eine botschafterin hat dort ihr haus
wurde auch sehr bunt da wollen
intellektuellen da sind das ist davon
die elite der ukraine die die
mittelklasse die in den letzten jahren
die ihr
ihre existenz dort aufgebaut haben und
jetzt sehen wir dass es eine zweite
solche verbrechen haben wir seit 80
jahren seit dem zweiten weltkrieg gar
nicht gesehen und auch stalin
säuberungen auch die waren eigentlich
aus um genug das was wir aus
schulbüchern kennen aber das was man
sieht hier ist auf auf den straßen von
von von von meiner heimatstadt ammann
fordert vom verkauf dass es nicht zu
verkraften und und die frage wie ich
also wie lange kann der bundeskanzler
wie lange kann diese
bundesregierung noch zu sehen und das
nicht tun was eigentlich richtig gewesen
wäre schon seit fünf wochen nämlich
sanktionen einzuführen damit so was sich
nicht wiederholt gasstopp vor allen
dingen darüber sprechen wir gleich ein
wenig nehmen sie unsere zuschauer und
uns noch einmal mit dort nach butscher
schildern sie uns noch einmal was ist
das für ein ort also vielleicht können
sie ein bisschen sagen einmal wie es
dort vor dem krieg aussah wer lebt dort
also butter nach berlin wo gekämpft
wurde und bilder haben wir auch gesehen
worden da wurden meine freunde sind alle
jetzt weg manche schicksale sind immer
noch unbekannt wir hoffen dass wir noch
leben aber aber man hat er seit wochen
keinen keinen kontakt also man man man
konnte sie nicht mehr erreichen und und
das war dann will ich das waren
beispiele dessen video ukraine seit der
wende aufgebaut wurde das ist ein
beispiel das sind dass man das leute
intellektuellen journalisten viele so
schauspieler das ist wirklich babelsberg
von von von von kiew und eine 1 1 kor
tolle gegend
eigentlich ein paradies auf erden vor
vor dieser höhle und das kann man gar
nicht beschreiben das kann man nicht in
worte fassen paul ronzheimer ist heute
dort gewesen viele stunden unterwegs
dort in diesem paradies wie andrej melik
es sagte dass es vor einigen wochen noch
war für ihn paul wir haben deine bilder
gesehen mit schrecken und haben uns
entschieden all das genauso zu zeigen
schilder uns mit deinen worten und jetzt
vielleicht gerade 12 stunden abstand die
du ja hinter dich gelegt hast bist
mittlerweile wieder im hotel was du ja
was sind deine durch den kopf geht nach
diesen bildern
nein ich bin noch unterwegs mit den
klitschko-brüdern hier und sie habe mich
gerade gefragt
als wir uns kurz hingesetzt haben ob ich
so etwas in meinem leben schon mal
erlebt habe ob ich so viele tote schon
mal gesehen habe
alle aufeinander in diesen häusern davor
gehabt dieses bild gezeigt von jemanden
der gerade kartoffeln geholt hat ein
anderer der fahrrad dort lang vor
das sind bilder die ich in der form noch
nicht gesehen habe ich habe schon viele
leichen gesehen kriegsgebieten in mossul
in anderen gegenden aber niemals in
einem land das so nah an berlin es zwei
flugstunden von ihrem wimmern von
kirchenleuten losgefahren zusammen mit
vitali und wladimir klitschko und das
muss man sich mal vorstellen wladimir
ist erst gestern abend aus berlin wieder
gekommen wo er dafür geworben hat
zusammen auch mit anderen manic dass man
mehr unterstützung bekommt und dann
kommt denn diese kriegs fälle mit uns
allen zusammen und wir sind dorthin
gefahren in einem konvoi dann kamen wir
dort an und man musste nicht suchen nach
dem laichen k sie lagen überall am
wegesrand in allen straßen und
man hat so klage sehen dass das
zivilisten waren den mann auf dem
fahrrad man konnte sich vorstellen
keiner kann soldat fährt mit kartoffeln
in den krieg das waren zivilisten das
ist klar ersichtlich und wenn man dann
mit den augenzeugen dort spricht über
das motiv ist und war team unser
ukrainischer kollege die waren mit
ukrainischen militär dort haben viele
zeugenberichte gehört von frauen wie
berichtet haben wie ihre männer im
keller hingerichtet wurden und wie diese
männer nichts mit dem krieg zu tun
hatten aber weil sie männer waren
einfach hingerichtet wurden auf grausame
weise es ist wirklich schwer zu
beschreiben dort was man dort sieht und
witali sagte zu mir auch immer wieder
also diesen ort so gut kennt also diesen
ort zum markt dass butscher eine solche
ja wie andrej melik ist schreibt ein ja
sein paradies war davor es ist in diesen
tagen so wichtig genau das zu
dokumentieren
auch weil das juristische folgen haben
wird aber vor allen dingen weil es ganz
erhebliche politische folgen noch mal
haben könnte dieses massaker dort von
butscher deswegen die banale frage paul
einmal um diese auch zu dokumentieren
die antwort wer war das
das waren russische soldaten und ich
würde auch selbst wenn das
tschetschenische selber gewesen sind
sind das für mich russische soldaten die
auf der seite und wladimir putin dort
gekämpft haben da gibt es keine zwei
meinungen es wird natürlich wahnsinnig
schwer zu überprüfen seien wer am ende
geschossen hat wer am ende sozusagen
diese menschen ermordet hat denn die
sind geflohen vor wenigen tagen dort aus
butterweck und wollen jetzt im osten des
landes weiter kämpfen du hast du schon
gesagt du bist weiter mit den
klitschko-brüdern dort unterwegs
wladimir der bis vor kurzem noch hier in
berlin war und mit ihm hast du genau
dort über diese bilder von buschehr auch
gesprochen paar wochen mal
die zu gewissen die hier die straße
unterliegen
denn sind die herren die wirkung
gewonnen man sieht dass sie im kopf
geschossen worden
exekutiert worden dass hier erzählt von
das was macht mode regime in der ukraine
polizei in der ukraine ist ein
vollkommen das ist kein
special operations
von
völkermord genozid darüber wollen wir
sprechen und wollen unsere runde
erweitern um wenzel mich hals geht in
deutschland direktor von human rights
watch ich bitte sie herzlich an diesem
sonntagabend herr michalsky sie arbeiten
das alles auch rechtlich auf sie
dokumentieren diese taten auch von
butscher zu welchem schluss kommen sie
heute
es deutet alles auf kriegsverbrechen hin
das muss untersucht werden und dann
müssen die verantwortlichen vor gericht
gestellt werden das wird hoffentlich
irgendwann mal passieren wir haben
ähnliche arbeit auch in syrien gemacht
wo die russische armee zusammen mit den
soldaten von assad massaker verübt haben
und
damals schon hatten wir uns gedacht wann
wird das überhaupt passieren warnt
werden diese leute vor gericht stehen
und jetzt haben wir erleben dass in
koblenz ein gerichtsprozess stattfand
gegen zwei folterknechte von assad und
die sind zu gefängnis verurteilt worden
das heißt unsere hoffnung ist dass die
verantwortlichen vor gericht gestellt
werden und die verantwortlichen sind da
nicht nur diejenigen soldaten die diese
gräueltaten verübt haben sondern auch
die der befehlshaber und befehlshaber
von deren befehlshabern wenn sie nicht
jetzt sofort so die russen selber das
jetzt untersuchen und entsprechend
wir wissen das wird nichts passieren
davon können wir nicht ausgehen deswegen
ist es jetzt wichtig dass auch die
ukrainische armee und unabhängige
untersuchungskommission
forensisch genau festhalten was da
passiert ist das bedeutet auch leider
dass jetzt die leichen nicht sofort
graben werden dürfen sondern sie müssen
wirklich von gerichtsmedizinern
untersucht werden das ist leider es
mutet natürlich in diesen stunden in
diesen tagen fast seltsam an dort so
einen formalen blick drauf zu haben und
trotzdem erklären sie uns einmal herr
michalsky warum das auch so wichtig ist
ohne auch auf ein möglicherweise nie
stattfinden oder so weit entfernten
prozess zu blicken warum ist es so
wichtig zu benennen und genau
herauszufinden ob das jetzt ein
kriegsverbrechen ist und ob es sich hier
um völkermord und genozid handelt
sei man diese leute die dafür
verantwortlich sind nicht ungeschoren
davon kommen lassen darf ja wir haben
das gemerkt wie wichtig zb für uns die
nürnberger prozesse gewesen sind nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg die ja auch
erstmal hervorgebracht haben was für
treue taten die wehrmacht verbracht hat
und das ist jetzt eben auch nötig in
diesem fall wir haben viele von solchen
fällen dokumentiert wir haben die
beweise wir sammeln beweise um dann für
den fall der fälle tatsächlich die
vorlegen zu können wir haben sie wir
haben das auch jetzt in den berichten
gerade veröffentlich gerade heute auch
ganz ähnliche fälle wie wir sie jetzt da
sehen in den gleichen orten allerdings
verübt schon zwischen dem 27 februar und
dem 14 märz dh wir haben die beweise
dass die gräueltaten diese schrecklichen
morde die vergewaltigung schon vor
vielen wochen stattfanden nämlich zu
anfang des monats danke herzlich allen
deutscher direktor von human rights
watch an wenzel michalski danke ihnen
und wir schauen einmal denn das rein was
der ukrainischer verteidigungsminister
heute gesagt hat dazu das ist alex er es
nie koffer hat ganz klare worte auch zu
diesen szenen aus butter gefunden
also liegt vorher melde die summer
school gegangen es war ein echtes
militärisches kriegsverbrechen wir
warten auf neue nürnberger prozesse ich
denke die deutschen kennen die
nürnberger prozesse bestens die nächsten
nürnberger prozesse sind gegen die
russischen faschistischen das sind die
worte des ukrainischen
verteidigungsministers und das sind die
worte des deutschen bundeskanzlers auch
in die schauen wir einmal rein er hatte
am nachmittag ein statement dazu
rausgegeben ein schriftliches und das
sind seine worte er spricht von
furchtbaren und grauenerregenden
aufnahmen die uns an diesem wochenende
aus der ukraine erreicht haben so
schreibt er es dutzende erschossene
zivilisten sind im busch entdeckt worden
schreibt er noch mal in einem gebiet
nördlich von kiew das wissen wir dass
bis vor wenigen tagen vom russischen
militär kontrolliert worden ist straßen
übersät mit leichten er beschreibt also
was er dort auf diesen bildern gesehen
hat notdürftig verscharrt körper das ist
von frauen kindern und alten die rede
die unter den opfern sind diese
verbrechen des russischen militärs
schreibt er dann der bundeskanzler
müssen wir schonungslos aufklären ich
verlange dass internationale
organisationen wie das rote kreuz zugang
erhalten zu diesen gebieten um die
gräueltaten zu dokumentieren die täter
und ihre auftraggeber schreibt er müssen
konsequent zur rechenschaft gezogen
werden der krieg in der ukraine befindet
sich jetzt in der sechsten woche
tausende unschuldige menschen sind ihm
schon zum opfer gefallen und das töten
geht unvermindert weiter und dann am
ende noch mal die forderung die worte
von bundeskanzler auf einen
waffenstillstand und an putin eben die
kampfhandlungen sofort einzustellen
darüber sprechen wir hier im studium mit
andrej melik dem ukrainischen
botschafter hier in deutschland das sind
worte da kommt das wort kriegsverbrechen
jetzt eben nicht vor da kommt das wort
völkermord nicht vor und da kommt auch
nicht vor dass man nochmal die
sanktionsschraube sofort heftig an dreht
ja und das ist das schlimmste denn man
sieht diese gräueltaten und und ist
angeblich immer noch nicht bereit
wirklich alles zu unternehmen nämlich
die sanktionen zu verschärfen das dass
putin sein appetit auf diese gräueltaten
verliert ja und und dass das kann man
gar nicht verstehen denn
also das ist die wende für uns und ich
hoffe dass auch die für die
bundesregierung diese diese massen
massaker in butter in
fort ordnung von kiew eine rote linien
sein sollte damit man endlich handelt
und das bedeutet embargo für öl gas und
kohle für natale auch das hat
deutschland immer wieder verhindert dass
das auf der eu-ebene dieser sanktionen
eingeführt werden denn sonst kann ich
mir gar nicht vorstellen wie kann man
überhaupt leben schlafen wenn man nach
diesen bildern diese starken worte
findet aber nichts tut die grüne
außenministerin und der grüne
wirtschaftsminister genetik heute einen
kleinen schritt weiter beide sprechen
sofort von neuen noch härteren
sanktionen benennen diese aber nicht
haben sie möglicherweise informationen
in welche richtung das geht geht dass
seitens der grünen minister in richtung
eines sofortigen gasstopps oder auch
dort nicht wir haben gar keine
informationen und wir hoffen dass die
deutschen hier zumindest in eine eine
führende rolle spielen werden in brüssel
um endlich die härtesten sanktionen auf
den tisch zu legen
die die die überhaupt möglich sind dann
was was sonst sollte noch passieren
chemischer tagen oder worauf wartet man
dass man die ultimativ ssten waffen und
da sind die schärfsten sanktionen auf
den tisch lektoren und ich kann das gar
nicht verstehen ich hoffe dass der
bundeskanzler dass die aussenministerin
dass der bundesfinanzminister dass sie
wirklich alles tun und zwar morgen und
zwar sofort damit damit diese bilder
sich nicht wiederholen denn man muss
sich vorstellen es sind hunderte
ortschaften im süden im osten im
nordosten die seit fünf wochen unter
russischen besatzung sind und ich kann
mir ich will mir gar nicht vorstellen
was dort seit 39 tagen geschieht sie
gehen fest davon aus dass das nicht
butscher dass das so schlimm das ist
schon alleine was wir dort auf diesen
bildern sehen dass das jetzt kein
einzelfall ist dass das nicht ein
durchgeknallter russischer general ist
eine durchgeknallte russische einheit
die butscher dort derart zurückgelassen
hat sondern dass das flächendeckend
genauso aussieht in ihrer hand meine
kollegin hier meine ängste kollegin ihr
vater lebt im süden drogerie nicht weit
von dem entfernt seit ersten tag in
gefangenschaft unter russischer
besatzung unter sitzt seit 39 tagen im
keller ohne strom ohne funk ohne nichts
ja und das was er hört dort da sind
schon fsb leute seit langem seit wochen
und da werden die häuser der werden
listen durchgearbeitet werden aktivisten
verschleppt getötet gemordet und butter
ist nur ein
beispiel dessen was seit 39 tagen
wahrscheinlich in vielen in hunderten
solchen ortschaften geschieht ja und
dass das kann man nicht mehr durch das
kann man nicht mehr dulden ich dann
gehen an diesem nochmals zu schwierigen
tag für ihren besuch im studio herr
mählich oder ukrainische botschafter der
sich so viel kritik auch in diesen tagen
gefallen lassen muss immer wieder auch
seitens der deutschen politik und der
man merkt dass im studio versucht
irgendwie worte zu erhalten zu fassen
für das was dort heute in seinem land in
seiner heimat passiert ist danke ihnen
und wir sprechen mit dem langjährigen
nato-general hans lothar domröse über
diese kriegsverbrechen so wurden sie
auch in dieser sendung hier benannt
schönen guten abend peter möse ist das
ja auch andere bayerische
auseinandersetzung was wir da sehen wir
sehen sie will listen die vom fahrrad
runter geknallt werden die mit ihren
kartoffeln auf dem weg vom einkauf
offenbar zurück weg geknallt werden
ermordet werden dort auf der straße
wir sind schreckliche bilder die wir
dort sehen und die erinnern mich
persönlich natürlich an die zeit 19 95
in bosnien das reh benutzer von 1999
kosovo wir eingeschritten sind die nato
eingeschritten ist um den genozid zu
unterbinden und das derzeit weiß ich
dass es das international commission on
missing persons und das internationale
rote kreuz gibt die mit wunderbaren
menschen diese forensiker diese fälle
aufarbeiten
anklagen und dann verteilt werden das
muss ich auch geschehen es ist
fürchterlich was hier passiert
es wird immer wieder jetzt in diesen
tagen auch die rede von joschka fischer
von damals zu hören wieder 1999 als er
aufgestanden ist an diesem
sonderparteitag der grünen hat damals
ein farbbeutel abbekommen aus den
eigenen reihen um zu dann später am
rednerpult zu rechtfertigen warum er
plädiert für ein militärisches
eingreifen damals im kosovo-krieg andere
lage jetzt und doch erinnert es uns in
diesen tagen wieder an sein nie wieder
krieg so hat er damals das eigene
eingreifen gerechtfertigt was fehlt
ihnen im moment ein wenn wir diese
bilder ausputzer sehen und dann davor
stehen und sagen mit unserer
historischen verantwortung nie wieder
krieg
das sagte ich dass wir sofort ein weil
ich selbst betroffen aber der
wesentliche unterschied ist natürlich
dass serbien nicht russland ist und
russland nicht serbien wir haben es hier
mit einer weltmacht zu tun aber die
verhaltensmuster sind der
tragischerweise genau die gleiche
marodierende soldaten die sie nicht ans
kriegsvölkerrecht hätten die sich nicht
erhalten macht so gering wie möglich an
zu üben gegen kombattanten nicht gegen
zivilisten das war es ja die zerstörung
der häuser kirchen
krankenhäuser hier sehen wir das jetzt
exemplarisch bei einzelnen
offensichtlich unschuldigen zivilisten
das kann ich nicht sagen das muss
untersucht werden das muss angeklagt
werden und zur rechenschaft gezogen
werden aber ich werde sicher dass der
präsident putin natürlich kann mir das
nicht beeindrucken wird deswegen müssen
wir die stimme
stimme erheben aber kann letztlich darf
letztlich ganz kurze antwort herr
domröse eine weltmacht sich offenbar so
was erlauben
nein er steht auch schon völlig isoliert
da hat ja nur noch freunde diaz hat und
lukaschenko
sonst ja nix china ist auch aufenthalten
und distanz gegangen als er ist völlig
isoliert und in richtung
iranische mullah-regime
danke ihnen für diese klaren aussagen an
den langjährigen nato general hans
lothar domröse hierbei mit live danke
ihnen
das alles an einem schrecklichen tag an
dem uns die bilder aus butter
schockieren und das sind noch die
falschen worte die machen uns
fassungslos an diesem tag an vorort von
tieren
27001 wo hatte diese stadt marl und
jetzt ist sie ja sinnbild für ein
massaker für ein kriegsverbrechen
geworden